an der grenze zur ukraine droht
kriegsgefahr und nachdem schon russland
vor einigen jahren in teile der ukraine
einmarschiert ist gibt es jetzt weitere
drohungen dass die russen in weitere
gebiete gehen und weitere teile der
ukraine annektieren gerade jetzt
bräuchte es eine klare haltung der spd
die die deutsche bundesregierung anführt
aber wir müssen feststellen die spd hat
ihren moralischen kompass bei der
sogenannten russland frage verloren olaf
scholz nimmt neben joe biden nicht mal
das wort nord stream 2 in den mund
obwohl der us präsident dass während
einer pressekonferenz klar artikuliert
und auch die internationalen partner
erwarten dass wir ein signal setzen nord
stream 2 ist erledigt wenn russland in
weitere teile der ukraine einmarschiert
ähnliches gilt für manuela schwesig die
bei vielen gelegenheiten sagt nord
stream 2 soll in betrieb genommen werden
und die geschehnisse in russland bei
vielen pressekonferenzen und
öffentlichen auftritten nicht wirklich
erwägt und es gibt weitere personen an
der spitze der spd der fraktionsvorsitz
wolf mützenich ist dazu nennen aber
natürlich auch altbundeskanzler gerhard
schröder der mittlerweile zu einem
lobbyisten von wladimir putin geworden
ist und ich kann die spd nur auffordern
zeigen sie eine klare haltung bei der
russland frage davon hängt der frieden
in europa ab aber davon hängt auch das
ansehen deutschlands gegenüber unseren
internationalen partnern ab so wie es
derzeit in der spd läuft kann es nicht
mehr weitergehen
wir habe ich direkt eine nachfrage herr
doktor klasse sie es heute sich noch
trauen sich so zu äußern haben sie nicht
angst dass sie wieder anwaltspost von
frau schwesig nach hause bekommen das
richtig habe ich vor einigen tagen
bekommen wegen auch kritische äußerungen
zur frau schrie sich bei einer anderen
talkshow und ich kann nur sagen ich
lasse mich davon nicht einschüchtern und
ich lasse mich auch davon nicht mundtot
machen weil ich es enorm wichtig finde
dass gerade wie auch als opposition im
deutschen bundestag deutlich machen dass
die spd bei der russland frei keinen
klaren kurs hat und dass das was viele
spd-politiker derzeit äußern ist völlig
unterschiedlich deutschlands ansehen
schadet deswegen kann ich nur ein sagen
ich bleibt weiter dran und sie waren
nicht erstarren ich meine wenn man die
anwaltspost aufmacht und plötzlich ja
ich war schon erstaunt weil das auch
gerade unter kollegen in der politik aus
meiner sicht nicht der normale weg ist
und auch ist sich normalerweise so
gehört dann ruft man vielleicht mal an
und sagt hat die äußerung fand ich jetzt
nicht okay dann klärt man das beim bier
oder bei einem telefonat und in der
regel ist auch gut es handelt sich ja um
eine kritische aussage aber natürlich
nicht um eine beleidigung das wäre auch
gar nicht mein stil und deswegen muss
ich sagen hat dieses verhalten mich doch
etwas befremdlich gestimmt das heißt
dass die spd jetzt wie ein
aufgescheuchtes re im moment weil diese
assoziation mit schröder so schwierig
ist es ich habe heute die
pressekonferenz von scholz und pushen
angeschaut und er hat zweimal gesagt ich
habe den größten respekt für gerhard
schröder und stolz neben ihm ist
erzittert und man dachte oh gott geht
diese parteien wenn man ganz bei ihnen
ja ja das ist ja auch vor allem nicht
besonders souverän
also wenn man gleich sagt arman droht
mit einer klage und schaltete die
anwälte ein also ich versuche immer
andere wege zu finden und auch stolz
heute und das noch mal zu
vervollständigen in dieser
pressekonferenz gesagt von einem wert
von einem ehemaligen politiker
gesprochen und meinte eigentlich den
altbundeskanzler oder wie heißt es
korrekt bundeskanzler gerhard schröder
also der eigene parteifreund wurde von
olaf scholz heute in dieser
pressekonferenz putin über dann als
ehemaliger politiker bezeichnet viel
größer hätte watsch'n gar nicht
ausfallen können und das ist nicht für
die missachtung genau hat auch gesagt er
spricht nicht für die bundesregierung
ich stimme ihnen in vielen dingen zu
applaus was ihre abrechnung gerade auch
mit dem kurs der spd in der russland
frage an gegen heute bei dem auftritt
von olaf scholz im kreml muss ich sagen
war das schon ziemlich souverän was olaf
scholz da hingelegt hat und das war auch
ziemlich deutlich bei allen
diplomatischen floskeln dies dennoch
gibt war ziemlich deutlich auch im ton
aber
was mich so ein bisschen hier umtreibt
und die spd hat ja auch ein starken
flügel der aus der friedensbewegung
kommt ich frag mich schon seit tagen wo
bleiben eigentlich die ganzen
demonstrationen
vor der russischen botschaft hier in
berlin vor den russischen konsulaten und
zwar die demonstration der
friedensaktivisten die ja sobald amerika
irgendwo nur möglicherweise sich
einschalten möchte militärisch um
freiheit zu verteidigen direkt auf die
straße gehen und demonstrieren ami go
home aber wenn der aggressor wladimir
putin die ukraine zusätzlich also noch
mal stärker unter seine kontrolle
bringen möchte dann ist hier auf diesen
straßen quasi gehen der lehre sind die
friedensaktivisten alle zu hause liegen
in den betten oder schauen verdacht bei
bild das ist einerseits gut weil
einerseits
daher die gucken auch noch mit ca das
ist toll das ganzkörper einnahmen bringt
ungefähr sagen ja mit bezug auf
klimaschutz vorher oder nachher könnten
sie demonstrieren gehen das wäre wichtig
um überhaupt glaubwürdigkeit zu haben
ein friedensaktivist ist nur dann
glaubwürdig wenn er jetzt gegen putin
demonstriert wenn nicht ist ja nicht
glaub ich
habe eine nur eine frage zu den nord
stream zwei wie abhängig sind wir von
diesem pipeline oder wie abhängig werden
wir dann wenn nordteams zwei online käme
das eine sehr gute frage man kann glaube
ich klar sagen es wird sehr teuer die
usa haben wir zugesagt sie würden dann
flüssiggas liefern aber ist dass im
transport viel teurer als gas über eine
pipeline und die frage ist gibt es dann
ausreichend mengen und wenn es nicht
ausreichend mengen gibt dann steigt
natürlich automatisch auch der preis
in den vergangenen jahren das muss man
auch ehrlicherweise sagen sind in der
energiepolitik aus meiner sicht einige
fehler gemacht worden man hätte zum
beispiel nicht erst aus der kernkraft
aussteigen sollen und dann aus der kohle
sondern wir hätten auf kernkraft so wie
andere länder auch setzen sollen und
gleichzeitig auch auf den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das maya von
finnland bis frankreich über viele
osteuropäische staaten ganz viele andere
nachbarn in europa und daher ist das
natürlich schon ein gewisser harakiri
kurs dann sagt man geht aus kernkraft
raus man das kohle raus
gleichzeitig gibt es probleme mit dem
gas und man hat sich noch bei dieser
geopolitischen lage
gewisser weise von russland abhängig
gemacht ich habe immer auch davor
gewarnt und glaube dass das nicht der
richtige weg ist aber man kann auch
nicht sagen man setzt sich für eine
stärkung des völkerrechts ein und man
sagt wir stehen auch partnern wie der
unter ihnen bei wenn russland mit
weiteren überfällen droht aber sagen das
gilt aber dann nicht mehr wenn wir
irgendwo wirtschaftliche folgen spüren
ich bin erstaunt und muss sagen ein
bisschen auch befremdet darüber wie groß
doch der antiamerikanismus auf der einen
seite hier in deutschland ist also nicht
mal jeder zweite bundesbürger sagt nach
studien dass amerika also unser starker
partner ist da sind wir in europa
tabellenletzter aber es gibt eine sehr
sehr große neigung hinzu wladimir putin
und das ist doch muss ich sagen ehrlich
gesagt sehr erstaunlich also wenn man
das jetzt mal ganz stark schwarz weiß
malt dann sehen wir doch wo die freiheit
zu hause ist und wo die freiheit nicht
zu hause ist und wie kann ein land dass
amerika extrem viel zu verdanken hat
eigentlich den wichtigsten den besten
und den stärksten partner den wir haben
so immer wieder vor den kopf stoßen die
kann es auch die spd übrigens und wie
kann man arbeitet ja gerade die spd
deswegen auch meine scharfe kritik an
der spd wenn man sich gestern zum
beispiel rolf mützenich anschaut im ard
morgenmagazin dann spricht der
angesichts der tatsache dass
hunderttausende russische soldaten die
im kriegen umzingelt haben auch noch
davon dass es berechtigte
sicherheitsinteressen russlands gibt
natürlich hat russland
sicherheitsinteresse und es gibt
berechtigte aber wenn man angesichts
dieser lage auch noch teilweise negative
von wladimir putin aufnimmt und die hier
in deutschland sträubt dann braucht man
sich nicht zu wundern dass sich auch der
anti amerikanismus
ausbreitet und wir waren immer in
deutschland stark und haben unsere
sicherheit und freiheit auch daraus
gesagt weil wir ein enges bündnis mit
amerika und dafür müssen wir uns
einsetzen und sie haben einen punkt
völlig zu recht gesagt ich sehe auch
viele demos da heißt dann immer ami go
home oder irgendwelche anderen parolen
ich sehe aber keine demos gegen china
menschenrechtsverletzungen finden dort
statt die chinesen haben weil mich das
an immer einmal verloren bei mir indes
aber gibt es kaum in deutschland
auf eine ausnahme aber
wirklich immer immer immer eine
wahrscheinlich so formulieren wir haben
mehr deutlich mehr antiamerikanische
demonstration und parolen als
demonstration gegen chinas gewann auch
gegen russlands gefahren und das ist
natürlich absolut falsch und teilweise
auch verlogen dann wir haben ja diese
pressekonferenz heute gesehen und das
muss man auch sagen hat olaf scholz
schon gut immer wieder pariert das war
wasser was mir putin dort zum besten
geboten hat zum teil also das best of
fake news also ja man widersprechen
müssen zum teil auch putin sprach einmal
zum beispiel vom genozid im jugoslawien
das hat ja
gesagt dass dortmund ii hat gesagt es
gab einen angriffskrieg ein krieg der
nato russland oder china gesagt wir
waren dabei sind aber ein gewisser ein
völkermord zu stoppen hat etwas völlig
anderes ist ja putin hatte hat er auch
einige vergleiche gebracht mit dem
genozid die nicht okay waren und da
hätte scholz aus meiner sicht dann
widersprechen müssen ja aber faktum ist
dass
putin ihr eine propagandashow auch heute
hat versucht wieder abzuziehen in die
olaf scholz doch durchaus immer wieder
reingegrätscht ist also das thema
jugoslawien die nato auch als angriffs
allianz darzustellen zeigt eigentlich
dass putin ein mann ist der nur in krieg
und frieden denkt und der nato wirklich
attestiert sie wäre genauso aggressiv
wie er das ist oder wie das das
sowjetreich war ist sie aber natürlich
nicht wissen wir ganz genau
von daher sind diese ganzen vergleiche
die er heute auch gezogen hat eigentlich
nur dazu da gewesen um noch mal zu sagen
warum er eigentlich in die ukraine
weiter an ihrem finger hat man gegenüber
nur mit einer gewissen härte begegnen
das haben ja auch die vergangenen tage
gezeigt und diese härte liegt olaf
scholz im moment nicht an den tag er
sagt dann ergibt der ukraine ein
bisschen geld aber waffen kriegt die
ukraine nicht zur selbstverteidigung und
man will sogar den daten aber das muss
ja arbeiten wir haben klar dass die
frage nicht einmal mit der lieferung
hatte die bundeskanzlerin merkel die ja
noch nicht so lange aus man ist auch nie
waffen an die ukraine geliefert die
frage hat er sich damals noch nicht in
der form gestellt wie jetzt aber unter
merkel sind zb was man die verstärker
geliefert als besetzt dass man sich wird
aber die sind damals also die waffen
sind die passion ärger geliefert werden
also unter merkel ist er schon auch
passiert